ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
SINCE THE FRIDAY RELEASE OF THE
G.O.P. HOUSE INTEL MEMO,
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR LACKEYS IN
THE LAMESTREAM MEDIA HAVE BEEN
IN OVERDRIVE, ATTACKING ON THE
FOREFRONT.
FIRST, THEY DOWNPLAY THE MEMO --
IT'S A BIG NOTHING.
>> AS THE NEW REPUBLIC PUT IT,
"IT WOULD BE EASY TO COMPARE
NUNES' MEMO TO GERALDO RIVERA
OPENING AL CAPONE'S VAULT."
MISLEADING.
>> Laura: FOR MMO THAT IS
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIMEY
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIMEN
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIMEO
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIMEI
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIMET
ARE SURE SPENDING A LOT OF TIME.
SECOND.
THEY SHOWED US THAT THE MEMO'S
AUTHOR, DEVIN NUNES, IS A REALLY
BAD ACTOR.
DID YOU KNOW HE'S COLLUDING WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
>> I BELIEVE THIS WHITE HOUSE
WORKED WITH CHAIRMAN NUNES TO
CONCOCT THIS IDEA.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY POSSIBLE
THAT HE COORDINATED THE WHOLE
EFFORT WITH THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: THAT IS A NICE
DODGE.
I LOVE HOW THEY ARE TRYING TO
SUGGEST THAT THE MEMO WAS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED WHILE
IGNORING THE FACTS IN THE MEMO
THAT DEMONSTRATE THE ENTIRE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION WAS
POLITICALLY AND MOST GATED
DEVIN NUNES HAS WORKED TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF CLINTON AND
MUELLER INVESTIGATION SHOULD BE
PERSUASION.
AND I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE NO ONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ABUSE OR EXCUSE THE RULE OF LAW
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
GOVERNMENTS CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO
TARGET THEIR POLITICAL ENEMY.
WELL, THEY DO IT, THOUGH, DON'T
THEY IN CHINA AND NORTH KOREA
AND, YOU BET, AND RUSSIA!
MY QUESTION IS WHAT HAPPENED TO
ACCOUNTABILITY?
HOLDING GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE?
THIRD.
THE DEMOCRATS CLAIM THAT TRUMP
IS GOING TO USE THE MEMO TO STOP
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION AND
[WHISPERING]
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
COULD THAT --
>> IF THE PRESIDENT USES THIS
FAKE, HORRIBLE RELEASE OF
COULD PARTICIPATE IN    IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> I KNOW THERE WOULD BE H
MINUTES OUTCRY, THERE WOULD BE A
CHAMBER, TAKES IT TO THE NEW
LEVEL.
THEY PASS AROUND MMO IN THE
MORNING, WE WILL SAY CHERRY
PICKED ONE DAY, WE WILL GO --
GOING TO FIRE ROSENSTEIN
DESPITE, AS I UNDERSTAND IT, HIS
DISPLEASURE WITH SOME OF
ROSENSTEIN'S STUPID DECISIONS,
INCLUDING SIGNING OFF ON ONE OF
THOSE WARRANTS TO SURVEILLED
CARTER PAGE.
BUT FOR JUST A MOMENT, LET'S
ACCEPT THEIR SILLY SCENARIO.
THE FIRING OF ROSENSTEIN MAY
TRIGGER A POLITICAL FRACAS.
AND MAYBE IT WOULD BE UNWISE.
I WOULDN'T DO IT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT SURELY HAS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO FIRE
ANYONE IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
SO I FAILED TO EXACTLY SEE HOW
THE DEMOCRATS INSIST THAT WITH
THE RELEASE OF THIS MEMO, TRUMP
AND NUNES ARE PUTTING THE FUTURE
OF THE ENTIRE FBI IN JEOPARDY.
>> TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE FBI
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
REALLY NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
DISCREDIT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, TO THE PRESIDENTS
BIDDING.
THIS IS A WAR ON THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS A WAR ON THE FBI.
NOW WHO WAS CARRYING OUT A WAR
AGAINST THE REPUTATION AND
INTEGRITY OF THE FBI, IF ANYONE
DID?
WELL, I'D SAY IT'S FORMER OBAMA
FORMER OBAMA DEPUTY ANGELA CADE
ANDREW McCADE.
JEOPARDY BY ERODING CONFIDENCE
IN ONE OF OUR TREASURED LAW
ENFORCEMENT INSTITUTIONS.
YOU CANNOT START SPYING ON AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN AS SOME KIND OF
INSURANCE POLICY AGAINST A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE YOU DON'T
HAPPEN TO LIKE.
IN FACT, YOU CANNOT SURVEILLED
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN BASED ON
IN
IN A FISA APPLICATION FOR BY A
ADDRESS THE CENTRAL POINT OF THE
NUNES HOUSE INTEL MEMO.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS
REMEMBER WHEN DEMOCRATS USE TO
CARE ABOUT PROTECTING AMERICAN
VARIOUS WAYS THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION WAS ENDANGERING
THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
THEY WARNED ABOUT THE PATRIOT
ACT, THE GROWING SURVEILLANCE
INFORMATION ACT BY RECLASSIFYING
DOCUMENTS AS UNCLASSIFIED BUT
SENSITIVE.
AND THE LIBERALS EVEN COMPLAINED
AT SOME OTHER CIVIL
LIBERTARIANS, ABOUT THE FAIRNESS
OF THESE LONG NO-FLY LIST.
BUT THIS IS MY FAVORITE PART OF
THIS ACLU LIST OF GRIEVANCES
WITH NUMBER EIGHT.
POLITICAL SPYING, IT WAS CALLED
THE PERMIT OF THE OFFENSE HAVE
AMERICANS THROUGH THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT, THEY LEARNED
GROUPS SUCH AS QUAKERS, PEOPLE
FOR THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF
ANIMALS, GREEN PEAS, AND THE
NATIVE AMERICAN ANTIDEFAMATION
ASSOCIATION, -- GREENPEACE GOT
SURVEILLED, BUT I GUESS CARTER
PAGE AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE
MEMBER PRODUCTION.
ABUSES.
>> FISA COURT PROCESS IS ONE OF
THE MOST ONE-SIDED APPROACHES IN
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT.
I KNOW OF NO OTHER COURT THAT
>> THERE SHOULD BE SOME
ADVERSARIAL PROCESS, CHALLENGING
IT, JUST AS WE SHOULD IN ANY
CASES WHERE THE COURT HAS THE
BENEFIT OF HEARING THE OTHER
SAID IN MY EAR, HE WAS ON RT TV!
DID YOU SEE THAT?
THAT'S GREAT.
LOOK WHAT COULD HAPPEN WITH THE
FISA COURT!
BUT NOW, HOWEVER, FISA IS BEYOND
REPROACH AS LONG AS IT'S USED
TOWARDS THE EVER NOBLE GOAL OF
DESTROYING DONALD TRUMP.
OR PREVENTING HIM BACK THEN
BEING PRESIDENT AT ALL.
TODAY ON MY RADIO SHOW,
NEWT GINGRICH AGREED THAT A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION SHOULD BE
UNDERTAKEN TO DISCOVER HOW THE
FBI PURPOSEFULLY MISLED THE FISA
COURT AND MAY HAVE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE IN THE HILLARY EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
>> 98% OF FBI AGENTS ARE HONEST,
PATRIOTIC AMERICANS TRYING TO
ENFORCE THE LAW, BUT THEY ARE
TAINTED BY THE PEOPLE AT THE
VERY TOP WHO CLEARLY WERE
CORRUPT.
AND WERE CLEARLY VIOLATING THE
LAW.
THIS WILL LEAD TO A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION BUT FRANKLY, I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS NOT TAKEN
STEPS.
THE QUESTION IS WITH ROD
APPOINTED TO EXPLORE ANY OF
THIS?
OR WILL IT BE UP TO CONGRESS TO
FIND ALL OF THE RELEVANT
DOUBT ABOUT THE FOLLOWING.
AFTER ALL THEIR YEARS OF
CLAIMING TO BE ADVOCATES FOR
FAIRNESS, CIVIL LIBERTIES, THE